all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with the power
rangers yes we are and in this video
we're picking up from not the last video
but the video before that where billy
the blue ranger was about to surrender
to lord drakken in this dark alternate
reality right i don't remember what what
we called it in the video before this
video but regardless we'll just call it
the dark alternate reality
that's the easier name to call it but
what we actually end up getting here is
a kind of jumping back and forth between
the main power rangers universe and this
dark alternate universe and for the most
part it kind of seems to be a defeat on
both sides right that you ended up
having in the main power rangers
universe you had like trini and you had
jason and you had zach and all those
guys kimberly in them the ones that
didn't get pulled away into the altar
universe basically everybody except for
billy and tommy who have basically been
defeated by rita in her army of goldars
and then in this alternate universe
billy's basically surrendering to lord
drakken which is kind of nuts but then
suddenly you kind of get this
realization both of which come from
trini and that's one of the funny things
that kind of goes on here with the power
rangers story and really it was
something that was always intriguing
with the show and i felt like they never
really developed it right i mean i guess
when you look at the show like the
original mighty morphin power rangers
billy was the brain and like trini was
kind of where billy was but not really
and they never really seemed to push the
limits of what trini was really capable
of at least if i can remember correctly
right it's been 20 years since i watched
the show but basically in this instance
there's a couple things that trini
realizes first and foremost in this
alternate reality she basically realizes
that with a with a morpher inner
possession and being close to lord
drakken that lord draken's ability to
kind of warp and distort the powers of
people around him basically emanates
from his access to the morphin grid
right the the morph shield generators as
they're called and so being able to have
a morpher so close would allow them to
basically interact with the power of
lord drakken the other part of this is
that in this in the the main power
rangers universe that trini had been
analyzing the black dragon as it was
possessed by lord draken and as it had
been modified by him and so with both of
these versions of herself in these two
different realities the one in the dark
alternate universe actually uses her
morpher to basically disrupt the power
of lord drakken and his forces to
essentially render them powerless right
to strip them of their abilities and
then in the main power rangers universe
she actually seizes control of the black
dragon as it was possessed by lord
draken and then literally just like
brings it on herself she just
reprogrammed the whole thing and then in
turn just like launches an attack
against rita repulsa which is crazy
right because you know using that and
using the the power ring of billy she's
able to use the dragon to tap into the
morphin grid which they previously
weren't able to do and to restore the
rest of the power rangers to their
normal power so they don't have to use
the the green power ranger coin to use
their abilities and so now you've
basically got these power rangers here
back to the status quo and you've got
lord draken rendered powerless and his
universe now with the power rangers
regaining their abilities it basically
allows them to reform the megazord and
that's when it all pops off right that's
when it all comes crashing down because
with the megazord basically being here
now there's really nothing rita can do
and it's kind of funny because trini
says like if you really think you're
that tough then challenge me right here
right now and the response of rita is no
like we'll do that at a different point
in time right so rita basically
ultimately ends up bailing out and then
you've got like all these giant gold
arrows that are basically being crushed
by the dragon zord while goldar prime
looks on now for those of you guys who
are a little unfamiliar with this right
kind of playing catch up here the whole
idea behind this was that rita basically
used goldar as a template in the same
way that they create monsters fenster
creates the putties different things
like that they basically created an army
of goldars all of which are basically
being destroyed by this by the the
megazord of the power rangers now one of
these goldar duplicates is kind of
hanging around goldar prime and sort of
makes this offhand a remark of like you
know man like you're getting all pissed
off about losing no wonder rita wanted
to get rid of you right like mr
sensitive over here and like that
duplicate of goldar gets killed by
goldar prime right so now we're just
back to there being one goldar again and
then following that kind of
transitioning back to this this sort of
alternate universe you basically end up
having like lord drakken this alternate
version of tommy who's completely
rendered powerless but the the fight and
the battle is not over because there
were reinforcements out there that were
outside this impact zone right so they
still have access to the morphin grid
and they still have their various powers
but at the end of the day it doesn't
really make much of a difference and so
what you end up getting is this kind of
knock down drag out fight between tommy
oliver from the main power rangers
universe and tommy oliver from this
alternate reality now here's the funny
thing about this right lord drakken
alternate tommy whatever you want to
call him he basically represents the
worst possible scenario for tommy oliver
from the main power rangers universe and
that's one of the things we've kind of
been hitting on when tommy first showed
up in the the power rangers mythos he
was a loner right he was just kind of
doing his own thing didn't really have
any friends kind of existed in isolation
the big change for him came after he
became the green ranger and was
essentially hoodwinked by rita that he
actually ended up allying himself with
the power rangers one of the things
we've talked about is that for lord
drakken that didn't happen that he
basically stayed with rita even after
her influence was over and so that's
what led to him basically conquering
this entirety of the world these are two
opposing dichotomies hope versus
hopelessness friendship versus isolation
right it's the internal struggle that
every single one of us deal with on a
regular basis right the feeling that
things are never going to get better
this is the life we're going to lead
forever right i mean i don't i don't
want to get you know too philosophical
here but like for a lot of you guys out
there you know to kind of make this more
tangible and more real you work like two
or three jobs right and there's no end
in sight and every day you wake up and
you feel exactly like you did the day
before where you dread the day that's
that you know regret how things are
gonna unfold and you go to your jobs and
you perform your tasks and then you go
home and you sleep and you wish to god
that it would just end right that's lord
drakken that's what he imbues the
philosophy he holds this almost kind of
hopelessness that things are never gonna
get better things are never really gonna
change tommy oliver from the main power
rangers universe reflects the idea that
things can get better that things can
change and that's what ultimately allows
him to get the upper hand on lord
drakken because that desire for hope
that belief that things can improve
that's what changes the world right
doing things changes things doing
nothing keeps things exactly as they are
and while he may have conquered the
world and helped rita pull all those
things off at the end of the day lord
drakken basically did nothing he stayed
exactly who he was he never changed he
never became better he never looked at
the possibilities that the world could
become a better place that his life is a
loner never having any friends that that
could never improve right he was just
this is the life that i have this is the
life that i live i'm going to be this
way forever and nothing's ever going to
get better from here right that's how he
perceived himself and how he perceived
the world tommy perceives it as things
can get better things can improve and
that's why he gets the upper hand here
that and the fact that he just seems to
be a better fighter you know and so the
results of this is that tommy oliver
gets the upper hand but you also end up
seeing the other power rangers coming in
from the main power rangers universe
because trini was able to use the black
dragon to basically open a dimensional
portal and then jump over right which is
cool because it basically reaffirms the
argument that tommy for the you know the
good tommy was making in saying that
like you know where where lord drakken
says like your friends will inevitably
let you down they will always let you
down if given the chance while it hasn't
happened now it will happen eventually
but good tommy's perspective here is
well i mean they may not be here right
now but they're still a source of
comfort because i know that they trust
me and while there will be times when i
may be disappointed there will be times
when i will need them and they may not
be there that's a momentary thing now i
guess if it happens constantly then sure
you know lord drakken was correct but
one failure does not mean a life of
failure it simply just means one failure
you know it's like a buddy of mine raj
once said i love to fail it's the only
way that you learn and it's the only way
you get better and that's true right
people people with this fear of failure
that's really what leads you to really
keep you from becoming better the fear
of failure is what holds you back right
and so it's one of the cool things here
because it's really as much of a
tangible physical representation that
tommy was right as it is him just
believing in himself and so ultimately
lord drakken's just kind of like well
whatever man if if this is this is the
day that's fine right i lose this battle
i lose this this bit of a conflict here
but it's only one day and ultimately
just jumps off right just jumps away and
it's one of these funny things because
it's a little ambiguous we don't really
know what he meant by that right that
maybe it's like this is only one
instance your friends have proved me
wrong this one time but in the future
they will prove me right we don't know
if it's something that on the nose and
that literal or if it's it's only one
day and over time you will become me
right whether it's because you encounter
alternate versions of me or any number
of things but you will ultimately end up
becoming me right this dark twisted
version of yourself regardless lord
drakken effectively jumps to his death
and so following that like everybody
retreats right they all basically bail
out they get out of there there's a
couple of little moments between the
various power rangers right where they
kind of talk to their alternate reality
counterparts as we know zach and the
main power rangers universe was
approached by rita at some point in time
to actually ally to her side he never
told the other power rangers and his
alternate reality version tells him tell
your friends right they'll understand
and and you need to be open with your
friends you need to let your friends
know what's going on with you and that's
one of the things that really made the
power rangers so interesting the power
rangers imbued this idea that when it
comes to friendships there really isn't
any holding back in order to really have
a close true relationship with a person
you have to absolutely let them see you
for who you are not who you want them to
see you as but for who you are in your
most vulnerable in your most weak let
them see that person and then in turn
you'll grow stronger now it is entirely
possible they could rebuke zack right as
that comes out and says hey so like rita
made me a deal and they're like no
you're evil get out of here right and
they kick him out of the power rangers
it would be crushing sure and it would
be devastating but that's the price you
pay for that human connection it's just
the nature of things and so ultimately
everybody just kind of teleports back to
their to the main power rangers universe
right the command center's still in
shambles right the whole place is still
just totally trashed and so they're kind
of like okay we gotta clean this up and
that's gonna suck
that's gonna totally blow balls here's
the funny thing though they're not the
only one who is teleported back you
actually end up finding out here that
lord drakken is one of the people who
was yanked back here presumably because
of his connection to his black dragon
zord and the idea that the zord was used
to open the portal and so his part and
partial connection basically ended up
bringing him along so now lord drakken
this alternate evil version of tommy is
in the main power rangers universe
question you have to ask is what comes
of him but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace